there are rumors galore that you will be
in spiderman
no way um what do you what do you think
of those rumors
hi andrew it's nice to see you nice to
see you over the zoom
uh i love this movie i thought it was
amazing you were incredible in it
how was it to tap into the world of
of youtube and social media stardom
it was fun it was really really fun so
gia
the director gia coppola and writer
director is a is a close friend of mine
and
she's been wanting to make tell this
story for
a lot of years and that there's a scene
in the film
where maya hawke's character vomits out
a bunch of emojis into a sink
and it feels like that's what this film
is for gia like she just needed to
kind of get it out of her system thanks
for checking out this video
my little niece worships these guys who
do and say nothing
for me it was fascinating and enticing
because
it's not a world i know much about and
also
the character is someone who feels very
very far away from me as a
as a person and i i was excited to see
if i could
find those character aspects and make
them feel authentic to me and kind of
dangerous
and a little bit scary and it's kind of
like
a counter-intuitive thing where i got to
go and be
totally free uncensored liberated and
uh not care whether i'm liked whether
i'm attractive whether i'm in it it was
it was
kind of like um everything that you try
to avoid in your life
you like i think it's especially in a
world of likes in a world of
you know our cachet being how liked we
are
um to to to kind of go against that
it felt kind of um
exciting and liberating and experimental
and there was no there was no pressure
on it because it's a it's an independent
film so
there wasn't a big pressure to be to to
you know to to be this kind of like
likable hero
um which is what i usually get cast as
um for the most part it was really just
incredibly liberating to um
to explore that you you did get to dress
up in all sorts of fun outfits
makeup hairstyles we know that you
love yourself some rupaul's drag race
you guest judged
on the uk version do you feel like your
love
of that show and that world helps you in
any way
prepare for this that's funny i haven't
thought about that
it's possible i mean yeah i do love that
show
i i i love watching it um because it's
the the people the the contestants the
the the performers are just you know
kind of
quadruple or like quintuple threats like
they sew they make their own costumes
they
they they paint their faces they they
they dance they sing their comedians
their act it's like
you know you know those that they are
the great artists of our time as far as
i'm concerned i'm just perpetually
inspired by that show
and the kind of the stream of creativity
and
uh and soul that comes through that show
um
i i would never ever compare myself to
um a great drag queen
um but but i i definitely felt
like it was a liberated thing to play
this character because it's so
not my rhythm or my style like who i am
as
a as a human so again it was it felt
like i was
it was it felt like i was a six year old
or a seven-year-old again i was just
playing and i wasn't thinking about
how it looked or the result or um it was
just totally free and
kind of pure id ego creativity
not really caring about about how it
turns out
just kind of just throwing stuff at the
wall this is just feeling
so right we're about to go stratospheric
we all saw the pap shots while you were
filming this movie
of you running down hollywood boulevard
uh for quite the nude scene
um how how was it to shoot that scene
was that
scary for you or was it fun it was both
because you know it's not if it's not
risky and dangerous then it's
it you know the more risky and dangerous
the more enjoyable and the more
release of adrenaline and the and the
more kind of um
you know it's that it's like you only
live once thing it was gia's favorite
scene to shoot
and you know she had tears in her eyes
after the first take but not not because
she was laughing so hard but because she
was
she was like emotional about how like it
was the most
her most favorite thing that she's ever
shot and i was like
it felt like i had just given her like a
christmas present or something and she
was like that was um
and i was like let's let's do it again
she was like what are you mean let's do
it like
i'm like i if you want to go again she's
like are you crazy i'm like no let's do
it
and sh i think she was just beside
herself with joy that that she found
someone foolish enough to um
to enjoy a kind of running naked down
hollywood boulevard
well it turned out hilarious it was
funny to see the pictures and then to
see
her vision come to life i was like oh
that's what yeah
this was all about yeah um i am running
out of time so
there are rumors galore that you will be
in spider-man no way
you oh boy what do you what do you think
of those rumors again
like i feel i feel like i'm in a game of
werewolf and i'm just saying i'm not the
werewolf
i am not the werewolf i promise you guys
i'm not the werewolf
um so yeah i mean listen
what people are talking about is a
really cool idea
and and and again i haven't received a
phone call but
you know is revisiting the role of peter
parker something that you would ever be
interested in it's weird it's not
something i've really thought about
because it
i really kind of i closed the book on it
for myself and
i haven't had need to think about it so
it's not something that i've really
considered um so yeah that's that's my
honest answer
okay that's fair um and then lastly do
you feel like this
movie in a way sums up the reason why
you
are not on social media no i don't think
so i think it's a reason
i think it's um i think i think that
that there is a you know it's in it
what's fascinating to me is
is in our culture why
we're so susceptible to um
giving platforms to people that maybe
don't have
that that maybe aren't the people we
deep down want to follow or that we deep
down
wanna kind of um hold as our
ethical center like
so i find that interesting that we that
we continually give
power to people that maybe um we
that maybe we'd be better giving our
power to people who care about us
in in in in different ways and or in
deeper ways
um so i find that really interesting but
no for me it's just
i i i it's not never say never but
for right now it's not something that i
feel the need to participate in in my
life
okay well maybe one day we'll look out
for your instagram
yeah i will let you know i will let you
[Music]
know